make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin all right what's going on
guys this
is rob and we are picking back up again
with secret wars conclusion uh we are
wrapping this whole thing up
in the last video we basically covered
black panther and probably the greatest
moment of his
of of the character's history i think
when he basically led an army of the
dead
while wielding the infinity gauntlet
against god king doom but as soon as he
shows up here
he immediately calls calls doom out
right he's like look like your whole
like this is all over right this is this
is all done and initially he kind of
looks at this and he believes that his
black panther is doing
right that it's basically this great big
huge scenario where you've got all these
you got all these armies that are
descended on battle world right you've
got zombies and all this kind of stuff
and it looks like something that black
panther did he's incredibly intelligent
in that way and that's why doom kind of
says this looks like something that you
would do because we've seen this kind of
thing happen before
right do more when doctor doom invaded
light or invaded wakanda we've seen this
kind of thing play out even though black
panther was more or less on his way out
by then we've seen that play out
and so in response like it's it's one of
these things where black panther is kind
of like you know to
to be a god like being good having all
this power and all that kind of stuff
you can't have that you're mortal right
you're basic there's not a whole lot to
you like you're basically pretending to
be a god as if you're somehow higher
than everybody else but you fall prey to
the same moral fallacies that everybody
else does
and so it's the same thing where he kind
of calls out black panther and says are
you really any different here and and in
reality black panther kind of sees
himself falling on the side of
righteousness and in a lot of ways he is
right he's not as emotionally invested
in battle world as god king doom is but
the result is that he basically ends up
using the infinity gauntlet to
re-materialize doom to essentially turn
him into glass it would seem and then
you have name of the submariner who
throws a spear and then shatters it all
and he's kind of like there's no way it
could be that easy right there's no way
it could be
that easy to destroy god king doom and
the response of black panther is
no it's not i mean it's not that simple
of course doom ends up reconstituting
himself and then he says
fine if that's how you want to do this
if you want to fight in this way then
let's fight the way god's fight let's
fight above the clouds
let's fight in the sky right let's fight
in the heavens the way the gods would
fight now
this right here is inherently the
problem with doctor doom and it's the
big difference between doctor doom and
black panther in terms of how they rule
their kingdoms and in terms of how they
see themselves right it's why
the attempts of doctor doom to call out
black panther didn't really work here
because t'challa is a king of the people
and and really for him his loyalty is
strictly to his people and the funny
thing about it is doom is much the same
way and the sins that he
loves and cares about his litvirian
people and he loves and cares about the
people here too
the major difference between these two
guys is how they see themselves in
relation
to their people that black panther sees
himself as one of his people doctor doom
sees himself above his people and that's
kind of the big difference there right
his arrogance is sort of what always
kind of seemed to be his shortcoming
that's something that we'll actually you
know sort of revisit here in a little
while and so from here we transition
over to reed richards right well i guess
both versions the
ultimate universe reed richards who we
call the maker and then reed richards
from the maine marvel universe the one
that you guys are all familiar with and
you basically have him you know
kind of have susan storm and valeria
arriving on the scene around the same
time that both reeds
show up here in order to access the
source of dr doom's power and susan
immediately calls him out right the only
real knowledge she has of reed richards
are the pictures she saw
when basically it looked like he and the
rest of the the heroes who survived the
incursions had killed doctor strange and
that's where reid's kind of like i'm not
the one who did this right like i'm not
the one who killed steven strange i'm
not responsible for that right it was
doom and where she responds and says you
mean god he says no
i mean victor right victor von doom is
not some god that you believe he is
however well
intentioned this world of his is i mean
to put things back to the way they're
supposed to be i mean to end this
charade and it's one of these things
where he's like this is not the life
that you were supposed to have right you
were never supposed to be married to
doctor doom right it's not the life that
valeria was supposed to have and it's
not the life that franklin was supposed
to have now notice this the the on the
surface you kind of look at this as yeah
i mean reid's right right it's not the
life they're supposed to have you know
they're supposed to be living in a
certain way no no reed's angry here
and he's jealous to a degree right he's
angry because of the fact that doom
stole his life and he's jealous because
of the fact that doom has his life right
like he's he's angry and jealous in
those ways and it's one of these things
where it's like these
this really isn't the way things are
supposed to be you're supposed to be
with me
that's basically what this is right like
you're supposed to be my wife you're
supposed to be with me these are
supposed to be my kids and it makes
sense right i mean keep in mind
this is susan storm and valeria they're
not from this universe
right like they're not from the main
marvel universe they were from some
alternate reality where reed richards
never existed or basically was never
part of the fantastic four
that's where they come from so they
they've never met reed right they've
never had any kind of a life with reed
but
reed is kind of talking to the susan
storm that he remembers having and the
valeria he remembers having in them
through
what's basically you know susan storm
and valeria here because these are the
biological children of
doctor doom right susan and franklin i'm
sorry valeria and franklin are the
biological kids of doom and so it's kind
of like you know i'm gonna like i'm
going to end all this right i'm going to
end
this whole great big huge farce and you
have this really cool battle something
that kind of takes place here on the
side you have this massive battle
between doom and black panther and it's
cool in so far as it's almost very
reminiscent of like the old like mad jim
jasper stories
reality was being twisted and distorted
in a whole bunch of just crazy
wonky looking ways and that's what's
going on here more so than that
these two are even the power of the
infinity gauntlet appears to be equal to
the power of god king doom now there's a
reason for this
god king doom despite having the power
of the beyonders does not have the
totality of the beyonder's power
that's owen reese owen reese has all the
power of the beyonders unto himself and
he
lends it he gives a portion of it to god
king doom to allow doom to do what he
needs to do and what this seems to
indicate is that the portion of power
that dr doom has is equal to the power
of the infinity gauntlet now why is that
the case
because the story had to be told that's
really the long and short of it right
and i'm not even trying to be glib this
story needed to be told and that's why
we are the way we are but it makes it
cool and it makes it interesting because
you end up having both reeds who
basically show up here and they
encounter the molecule man and it's one
of these things where
doctor doom and black panther are kind
of reduced down to just bare knuckle
fist fighting is really what it kind of
comes down to but you've also got
you know both reeds talking directly to
the molecule man and in the midst of
this conversation
the maker basically create like kind of
brings out this device and immediately
targets reed richards from the main
marvel universe and what this device is
designed to do is create what's
essentially a temporal bubble
that in the universe that the maker
comes from in the ultimate universe this
technology was used to basically
hyper-evolve people but what it can be
done
what it can be used for here is to
actually reverse people's aging to
essentially make them younger to reverse
them revert them back on an evolutionary
state and that's what happens with with
reid he literally starts reverting back
and turning and you know going into a
primate form and then will seemingly
kind of continue down until there's
basically nothing left whatsoever but
while that's happening where he kind of
makes this off-handed remark you know he
basically kind of tells them like like
when we were up there and you were
talking to susan you were displaying a
kind of weakness that cannot be
tolerated you were showing emotion
and that kind of weakness cannot be
tolerated here you've become a threat
right you've become a liability and
that's why he was targeted the way he
was and so he kind of asked who's
interested in a weepy god the response
of the molecule man is
me and he basically kills the maker
right he literally just kind of cuts him
into pieces turns them into what looks
like pizza and then presumably devours
it like he eats the he eats the maker
and then he tells reid like wake up
right like
doom's gonna be here soon and so you
kind of have this fight going down
between
between t'challa and and doom and doctor
doom ultimately ends up getting the
upper hand which you wouldn't think
would be the case because of the fact
that you know doctor doom
is just a guy who's pretty decent in
fighting you would assume and black
panther is a master of like multiple
martial arts you end up finding out that
black panther actually let himself lose
here and the reason why is because this
was all designed to be a ruse it was
designed to keep doctor doom
looking to the left while reed and
everybody moved on the right and so in
his frustration and his irritation
doom teleports directly to where to base
essentially to where reed and all those
guys are right he teleports directly to
their location
and that's when he confronts richard
this is all you're doing this is all
your scheme like all of this is is it
wreaks of you
it reeks of something that you would do
it smells like reed richards and he kind
of says like what i've done here like
while you may want to tear this down
while you may want to say that that you
could find a better solution there is no
better solution here right your entire
life
you've been distracted with the modern
concerns so precious to you and your
kind ethics and order in society when
all that's ever mattered was survival
i saved millions owen saved millions he
says what was it you said when you
appeared here on my world
all you could save was yourself you
couldn't even save your own family
that right there pisses off reed right
he's like how dare you like i'm god king
doom i've dared quite a bit and he
basically goes to snap his fingers and
kill reed and nothing happens
and the reason why is because what
molecule man's done is shut off doctor
doom's access to the beyonder's powers
now it's just doctor doom in his base
form versus reed in his base form now
here's the thing to understand here
about this about this
this conflict this is easy to look at as
something that's just kind of been there
right this is just reed richards and
doctor doom fighting at the end of
secret warsaw decide what happens next
no no this is a bad this is a fist fight
like this is a bare knuckle
drag out knock down fist fight that's
been waiting to happen for decades
just from a publishing standpoint we've
been waiting for this since like the
introduction of doctor doom and the
fantastic four there's always been
instances where doom has always been
jealous of reed and there's been
instances where reed was jealous of of
doom but regardless of this of the
scenario
this is the most bare bones like died in
the wool
natural conflict between these two guys
just bare bones
knocked down drag out bare knuckle
fighting more so than that there's
personal animosity here the stance of
doom is like does reid really think this
was easy that any of this has ever been
easy that would power really make
choices more palatable that if anything
it makes them harder because when you're
a person who just rules over a kingdom
all you really have to care about all
you really have to concern yourself
about is whether or not the people in
that kingdom stay loyal to you and
there's there's things you have to do in
order to ensure that right make sure
that they're they're safe they're
comfortable that kind of a thing but
when you're standing at the end of all
things right the end of the multiverse
and you have this absolute power at your
disposal and you have to
pick and choose between who lives and
who dies that's a heavy burden right
heavy is the head that wears the crowd
but it's the choice that doom made and
that means he accepted all the burden
that came with it so the question
becomes this
if doctor doom accepted the struggle of
what it meant to be king does he now
have
any real justification to complain about
it right you can't be a person who says
i believe in getting up at five o'clock
every morning and then complaining about
getting up at five o'clock every morning
right it was your choice
you chose this you now have no reason to
complain because it was a choice you
made if you don't like it do something
about it and it's kind of interesting
here because the stance of reid is the
difficult thing for him was sitting
there in this time period right and
you know once he once he emerged from
this this vessel and realized that doom
had basically stolen his life
he had to sit there and watch while he
planned and while he schemed and while
he mechanized in order to bring doom
down he had to all the while take those
feelings and push them down
in order to make sure he did what needed
to be done right that that doom
really did steal the family he stole the
life of of reed richards he wanted to
become reed and that's the funny thing
about this is that what it shows is that
doom's life is dissatisfactory right he
doesn't he doesn't
enjoy it he's unhappy with the life he
has when he compares it to the life of
reed richards he wants reed's life he
wants to be read like he wants to have
that lifestyle and i would dare say it's
not even
the nature of being like an explorer or
anything like that it's the fact that
reed never gives up
right reed never quits that reed always
keeps going reed richards is kind of the
walking talking embodiment of what a
superhero
is in in marvel comics he's marvel
comics most person at least
on a person a personality level is the
most pure version of superman that you
could get that doom in comparing himself
to reed
feels like a half measure and so that's
one of the things where he he asked reed
richards like
do you believe that you could have done
better like you think you're better than
i am
and the responsive read is no i don't
think i'm better than you are i think
you could have been better than what you
were and he says no no no
in this moment right now do you believe
that if you had all this power
you believe that if you had attained the
power of the beyonders at the end of all
things at the edge of all creation the
edge of the multiverse the end of it do
you believe
that if that power had gone to you that
you could have you could have done
much better than me you believe that
don't you and reed's response is
yes and so do you and the response of
doom is
he's like yes damn you like i agree like
i agree with what you're saying read
like like victor has
basically acquiesces here and says yes
fine you're right
if you had had this power you probably
would have done a better job than i had
owen reese hears that and says well if
both of you agree
snap right that's the end of battle
world just like that boom it all
basically comes to an end that you end
up having owen reese who gives all of
his power who
who basically takes away the power that
dr doom had and he gives it to reed
richards now in these moments when
everything is dying and everything is
being destroyed
susan storm valeria franklin like
they're all dead like they're all
basically being destroyed here uh you
know
everybody on battle world one of the
only people who survives
is when you when you have t'challa who
literally looks like he holds on to the
reality stone i know it's not red the
color of the stones change all the time
in marvel comics right just because it's
read in the mcu doesn't mean anything
right the reality stone i think has been
like two or three different colors over
the course of marvel's publication
history but he grabs a stone
and holds on to it to basically allow
himself to like survive the whole
experience
everything seems to go back to normal
and he basically wakes up in wakanda
kind of comes to in wakanda the stone is
destroyed but he's there right he's
there right back and
basically where all of this started and
so black panther kind of looks around
and says like right now you know in in
this world that we live in this earth
that we live on that space has basically
been abandoned by humanity that there
was a time in human history when humans
explore the space ways right when
in so far as like we went to the moon
and different things like that but
politics
and other priorities and spending have
given way or have kind of overtaken that
so humanity has lost its edge in
exploration humanity doesn't care about
exploring things and doesn't really
doesn't really care about improving
itself anymore humanity cares about
money and so we as wakandans we will be
the ones to lead humanity into a better
future right we will drag humanity to
the stars we will drag them into the
future
even if they don't want to go we will
make them go there right we will make
humanity become the best version of
itself and this is our very first time
it's our very first time that we as a
wakandan civilization
are looking to the stars and actually
leaving the planet right it's a big deal
the other part of this the next thing
that happens is we end up finding out
that miles morales who up to this point
in the ultimate universe his mom had
died that owen reese actually resurrects
her from the dead when everything seems
to go back to normal because of the fact
that
miles morales brought him a sandwich
right he basically says i owe you one
right for giving me a burger and so he
basically helps to kind of complete
miles life because up to the time that
this story was written back in 2015
a major part of mile's life was that he
struggled with the fact that he didn't
have his mom he struggled with that with
not having her in his life right with
the fact that she had basically died
that was something that was a huge
a huge turning point for his character
when it happened right when his mom died
it was massive hit form and so then you
basically pick up with kind of what's
going on here right with with you kind
of pick up eight months later you know
with everything that's sort of going on
in this moment and you basically kind of
get this explanation of what was
happening with regards to the collab
you know when when everything kind of
was destroyed right when battle world
came to an end
and when that power was passed on to
read richards that what reid richards
did is what he believed dr doom should
have done the entire time that at that
point in time when the incursions
completed right when we got to the end
of hickman's avengers and new avengers
there was no stopping the collapse of
the multiverse right there was nothing
reed could have done to end that the
difference is that dr doom made it he
made himself a king right he made a
kingdom unto himself
what reed richard's belief should have
been done is that it should have been
recreated right that once the beyonders
were basically destroyed the multiverse
should have been recreated again things
should have been set back to the way
they were before with a few changes here
and there
now this is where a lot of people like
myself said marvel missed a golden
opportunity to reboot and i still say to
this day marvel got cold feet i still
say that marvel got cold feet and they
ended up not rebooting because of the
fact that they were scared but it would
have been the smartest move to make
right because while reed says
things should have gone back to the way
they were before they may very well
could have and in fact they actually did
but the beauty of a reboot is that it
could basically kind of retell these
stories
not really retell the same old stories
but basically kind of give us a fresh
start for new people right the way dc
did with the new 52. instead they didn't
do that but what reid's doing here is
he's kind of have a multi-faceted system
going on
owen reese to kind of start with him
he's the foundation of all of this owen
reese is currently in the in possession
of the totality of the beyonder's power
right he's in
in total possession of that and so what
owen reese is doing basically he's
serving as this unlimited
repository of power because in creating
these universes basically owen reese has
the ability to create these universes
right so he has the power
that can be used to create the universes
franklin richards basically
coalesces that power into the form of a
universe as a universal shaper
and then reed richards is the one who
kind of directs franklin richards in
terms of what form and fashion these
universes
should for the most part take and that
each time one of these universes is
created that a portion of owen reese is
removed and put in that universe right
that's one of the things that hickman
covered towards the end of secret wars
is that the beginning of the incursions
was the fact that
owen reese was killed in a different
reality and that led to the destruction
of his universe and that this
ultimately kicked off the whole
incursion event and so it's kind of
setting things right right there's a
different owen reese in every single
universe every universe has to have one
now you would think and this is kind of
the irony of this you would think reid
would have kind of looked at that and
said ah but like maybe we shouldn't
though
right because like the destruction of an
owen reese leads to like the death of
that universe so maybe we shouldn't do
that right so that on the offhand
if like owen reese gets killed again in
some universe somewhere that it doesn't
start the incursions again we don't have
to worry about that uh that probably
would have been the smarter move
but ultimately not and the funny thing
about this is that from valeria's
standpoint
the biggest thing about all this is that
they have the ability now once this this
multiverse is recreated by owen reese
franklin richards and uh and reed
richards that they now get to explore it
and to kind of see how all that stuff
works but this was kind of the send-off
right to the to the fantastic four to a
degree but the other thing that we end
up finding out here is that reed has
basically brought back susan
and valeria franklin the members of the
future foundation right all these people
who had basically perished in the
collapse of the multiverse right in that
little moment when the ultimate universe
in the main marvel universe were
crashing into each other he brought them
back
right he basically restored them and we
know that because susan looks at him and
says like the the life raft had broken
and i thought we were done
and then you saved us right so rita gone
back to that moment right right before
basically he lost everybody and kind of
began reconstituting things
more so than that he basically says that
in looking at what he could do
that there were fundamental things some
small things that he realized he could
fix
that doom had kind of become a person he
kind of become a shut-in and really
isolated himself from humanity and his
face was really kind of an external
manifestation of that he didn't want
people to see who he was and he
basically hid himself and hid his face
behind a mask
initially it was i don't want people to
see my face that gradually turned into
i don't want people to see me and that's
why he just kind of remains so hidden
because that's kind of the
the problem with doom right that's one
of the major issues is that he's afraid
of the world right he's he's afraid of
the world seeing him for who he really
is
and fixing his face which is exactly
what reed did was a way to kind of make
doctor doom whole right it was
it was a way to kind of return him to
the person that he should have been
right that if he had never lost his face
in the first place and it hadn't set him
down this path of isolation then perhaps
all this kind of arrogance that he
that he had harbored in his early years
would have given way to a bit of modesty
and humbleness who knows but at the very
least it's a good shot right to just
kind of say hey
i don't really hold grudges against you
too bad here's your face back
but that concludes the event guys that
wraps up secret wars 2015 we are
done okay i want to know what do you
guys think right i'll post a comment
down below i want to
i want to know what you guys think what
did you think about the whole run
of jonathan hickman's avengers all the
way up to secret wars what did you guys
think because i say to this day
it's probably the single greatest comic
book epic that's ever been written like
it's amazing i absolutely
love this series of stories it's so cool
and i'm so glad i remastered it because
i just kind of had this itch to remaster
the whole thing and i'm glad we finally
finished it but it's been one heck of a
ride thank you guys for watching you
guys are amazing i love you guys to
death
but if you guys are new here to this
explained make sure you guys hit the sub
button to become part of the rob core if
you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
[Music]
peace
[Music]
[Music]
me
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
you